i'm out this is so ridiculous
you won't let me speak scott because
you're talking over me i'm so over to
scott for real as scott disick continues
to process the news of kourtney
kardashian's engagement to travis barker
we're just you know living our best
lives he's getting into some heated
arguments along the way courtney met her
soul mate that's got to be hard for
scott to absorb but i never expected him
to be so angry and wound up over this he
just needs to grow up and be a little
more mature during the most recent
episode of the famous family's new hulu
series the 38 year old reality star gets
into it with court's mom kris jenner
after learning he wasn't invited to her
birthday dinner for me to hear that you
are having a little soiree
and you don't think to invite me makes
me feel like complete
to be honest and while scott ultimately
gets the invite to chris's party the
awkward and tense moments just keep
rolling in this time between scott and
court's sister kendall jenner i didn't
really invite anyone to my birthday at
the dinner at my house yeah yeah but
literally that wasn't important
though that wasn't a party
yep another kardashian jenner birthday
party scott is upset he wasn't included
in never in a million years would
kendall not invite me to a birthday
dinner kendall explains that she had a
very intimate birthday dinner but still
says she didn't invite him because court
was going to be there i don't understand
why i should be left out well the 26
year old model wasn't feeling the guilt
trip i'm not ever trying to leave you
out even the night that they got engaged
i was the one that was literally like
all right like what about scott's
feelings though what's scott gonna have
i know that's true she was the one who
said great and i heard that and then you
don't invite me to your birthday
courtney at the end of the day is my
sister of course i want her there this
dinner was literally 15 people if it's
an intimate dinner and i'm not willing
to have an uncomfortable situation
and when scott refuses to let it go all
hell breaks loose i'm out this is so
ridiculous
you won't let me speak scott because
you're talking over me i'm so over to
scott for real despite the explosive
fight kendall did say in an earlier
confessional that she loves scott and
always will scott is is my brother like
we're basically blood at this point and
so it would be very weird if he wasn't a
part of our family and i don't think
there's ever going to be a day where
he's not a part of our family in some
capacity and while fans will just have
to wait to see how all that plays out
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
fans got a real insight into kendall's
culinary skills and let's just say we're
shook i don't know i'm kind of scared
there you go
don't cucumbers have seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
i'm not a good cutter so don't zoom in
on me
i'm not professional whatsoever
yeah that moment went viral with viewers
tweeting their shock and awe at her
haphazard veggie cutting listen kenny we
support your technique just stay safe
i know i'm kind of scared
[Music]